have y'all never met him I didn't know
if y'all met before this backstage
like right on so I want to talk about
your new book so your new book is called
the wind at my back which is such a
beautiful title and this picture by the
way what a great coverage it says so
much oh that moment yeah like it was the
first time that I was performing Swan
Lake
um at the Metropolitan Opera House and
Raven Wilkinson never had the
opportunity to perform on that stage as
a black woman and but you can see that
in your face in this picture and she
came on stage and brought me the flowers
and it's it's tradition in ballet that
it's only men that bring the flowers and
they're the ushers so we fought to have
this black woman come on stage you
should have been on that stage
performing and present those flowers to
me and I I just like crumbled because it
was a surprise and I like knelt down and
gave her the flowers and she picked me
up and she was like nope take them back
these are yours yeah I love that though
it's just the
I don't know the expression on your face
in this picture says it's like tears and
love and joy and everything yeah
admiration it's just like all there it's
very beautiful I love that it's the
cover thank you um can you tell us a
little about the book like why you felt
it was necessary to write yeah
um so you know I wouldn't be where I am
if it weren't for the incredible women
in my life uh mentors in my life and
then Raven coming into my life at such a
critical time I was still a soloist at
ABT and really struggling to find my
voice in place as a black woman yeah um
in in the ballet world and seeing her
you know she literally walked in my path
and my footsteps or I walk in hers but
you know 50 years prior and um and just
also to see how much hasn't changed in
the ballet World 50 from 50 years ago
and what Raven had experienced um uh I
just felt it was important for you know
again to see this uh the power of
intergenerational relationships and the
importance of mentorship and and having
those relationships with your elders and
so it's it's a story of Raven's life and
and my life and how they come together
and I don't think I would be a principal
dancer I would be here without the
relationship that we built and the
friendship that you know we had she
passed a couple of years ago now but she
just made such a big impact on my life
and showed gave me a bigger purpose of
what it is I'm doing like it wasn't just
about striving to be a principal dancer
but it was being an example and
representation on the stage for so many
and a hero and it is kind of sad now
that you say that like I didn't really
put that together but you just mentioned
the two of you because you're like
they're still not a big presence and
it's it's a shame it is yeah I mean it's
so important you know that beyond the
stage that I have a voice and that I use
my platform to to kind of get out there
and and to share uh you know the ballet
World bring it to more people and try
and bring more diverse to it but through
My Own Foundation then I've started a
program called the bebold program and
it's about free ballet classes and the
after school space at Boys and Girls
clubs in the Bronx is where we're
starting so it's yes looking back and
and giving opportunity uh is is so
important for me yeah well it surely was
look at that picture well speaking of
dips have y'all done that
I love that
this is a strange comedically I've been
looking at the way the world is and
because of the staff of Santa Claus my
family and my my niece Jess is a dancer
and I'm I don't know much about it my
wife is it was a dancer and I wanted I'm
just not into it I'm in comedy I mean
the most dancing comedians get as
burlesque which is a form of dance and
then I got into this thing about ballet
and I don't understand it but between
all it makes me emotional to think of
that this art form is an expression of
beauty
through the body and and they do it no
matter whether there's money or
attraction to it at all it's such an
honorable thing now I'm a huge fan of
ballet that they that people are so
disciplined yeah the comedy part is the
worst dictator in the world Stalin
murdered millions of people Jesus but
not the dancers
I love it but I my heart went out to the
people that produced this stuff and all
of our bad times but especially or fine
orchestras and then dancers people that
do that and you I just amazed at what
you people do and how you express it
it's art and love and design and
movement it's beautiful
and that's so cool that y'all got to do
the father I thought that was really
special what book did we tell that
whatever that book you read yeah it was
literally called Misty Copeland I had a
book that I read when I was like just
saw her backstage in the look on her
face she's like I was like
I was like my mom and I used to read
books like while she was making
breakfast and I had it was just like you
know picture books like a kid's picture
book but I read it every morning like
every morning so when when I heard I was
like oh
he was sitting right next to her
ah Misty's book is called the wind at my
back resilience Grace and other gifts
for my mentor Raven Wilkinson it's out
now y'all gotta check it out
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]